[Music]
the last week a week or so people have
been talking a lot about Robin Williams
who we lost which is obviously very very
sad story and and and a lot of us are
just trying to find moments that express
some of the joy that he brought us
people that got to work with him you
worked with him in mrs. mrs. Doubtfire
which was a massive hit what was it like
what was your experience working with
Robin oh it was mighty I mean I was such
a fan of this man's work and Sally
Fields who's in the movie so for me to
get that job in that particular space of
time was was just sheer magic I needed
the job and I got the job
yeah and he's very well known for and we
experienced it experience it here he was
always on and being funny and sort of in
an irreverent way you know when you're
just in the business of making a movie
I've heard that he he wasn't into okay
let's just be quiet and get the scene he
would just try and make other people
laugh oh he did completely so I mean we
did a scene in that movie where my
character Stu is at the table the dinner
table chokes on his shrimp it's a
beautiful scene and his character hates
my character because I'm with his wife
and we did a sequence where was my
close-up
they sent the kids away and he just let
it rip I mean he was just so
foul-mouthed and funny and completely
about Sally's character I'm just saying
foul things about character absolutely
sexual innuendo
[Laughter]
and you're just gonna get the take and
I'm trying to say the lines I mean I'm
following the script but he's going
community up to Pluto and back again
yeah so you know as an actor you just as
a supporting actor you give the man to
space and I kept to my text and just
danced around it how could I compete
with him but he was a very generous
kind-hearted human being and you know it
was a mighty blow yeah this certainly
was mighty blow thanks for sharing that
with us
you